اعلن رام بن براك رئيس لجنه الخارجيه
والامن التابعه للكنيست عن اخفاق الجيش
الاسرائيلي الاسبوع الماضي في عمليه
لالقاء القبض على اعضاء في مجموعه عرين
الاسود في مدينه نابلس يجتبه في ضلوعهم
بقتل احد جنود الاحتلال قال بن براك في
حديث لاذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الامر قد
يتطلب اسبوعا او اسبوعين لالقاء القبض على
المطلوبين مؤكدا انه لا يتم التهاون مع من
سماهم المخربين وان هذا ما يفسر اعداد
القتل المتزايده في صفوف الفلسطينيين
وكانت قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه قد اشتبكت
الاسبوع الماضي مع مسلحين في البلده
القديمه في نابلس عندما حاولت الدخول الى
احد المنازل لكنها لم تعثر فيه على
المطلوب
انتقلت القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واحدا
وعشرين مواطنا فلسطينيا في انحاء مختلفه
من الضفه الغربيه ليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم
واشار نادي الاسيره الفلسطيني الى ان
الاعتقالات تركزت بشكل خاص في مناطق
الخليل وبيت لحم واريحا ورام الله
وقلقيليه وجنين